WELCOME BACK EVERYONE.
RIGHT NOW, CHINA'S COMMUNIST
LEADERS AND POLITICAL ELITE ARE
GATHERING FOR DAY TWO OF THE
20TH PARTY CONGRESS.
SHE JINPING OPENING THE EVENT
ON SUNDAY LIKE HE HAS IN THE
PAST, LAYING OUT HIS
NATIONALISTIC VISION FOR THE
COUNTRY'S FUTURE.
THIS YEAR IS LIKE ANY OTHER
BECAUSE AFTER TEN YEARS IN
POWER, SHE IS POISED TO BE
SELECTED FOR UNPRECEDENTED
[INAUDIBLE] THIS PARTY LEADER.
I WATERSHED MOMENT FOR CHINA,
SELINA WANG REPORTS NO.
ONE THAT WAS YEARS IN THE
MAKING.
>> FROM A NATION OF FOLK
VILLAGES, TO SPRAWLING
METROPOLISES.
RECENT HISTORY, NO COUNTRY
MODERNIZES RAPIDLY IS CHINA.
NO ONE HAS CHANGED CHINA MORE
THAN SHE JINPING.
HIS INITIATIVE, IN EXCESS --
HIS KEY MESSAGE, MAKE CHINA
GREAT AGAIN.
ABOVE ALL ELSE, OBEY AND FOLLOW
HIS LEAD.
WHEN HE TOOK CONTROL OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY IN 2012,
THERE WAS HOPE THAT THE
BILLETED LOW-KEY LEADER WOULD
MAKE CHINA'S ECONOMY AND
SOCIETY MORE LIBERAL.
BUT SHE HAD A DIFFERENT
POSITION.
RESTORE THE COUNTRY TO ITS
FORMER GLORY WITH HIS COMMUNIST
PARTY FIRMLY AT ITS CENTER.
>> SHE JINPING SITS AT THE
PARTY, PARTIES IN SOME TYPE OF
CHINA.
CHINA SITS ON TOP OF WHAT.
THAT IS BASICALLY IN THE
PROGRAM.
>> SHE'S CHINA IS INVESTING
HEAVILY AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
INFRASTRUCTURE, RAPIDLY
MODERNIZING THE COUNTRYSIDE AND
THE MILITARY.
HE'S REASSERTED PARTY CONTROL
OVER BUSINESS AND SOCIETY.
BUILDING THE WORLD'S MOST
SOPHISTICATED SURVEILLANCE
STATE.
CAUTION PEOPLES FREEDOMS DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND LOCKDOWNS.
SHE JINPING CRUSHED DREAMS OF
DEMOCRACY IN HONG KONG.
OVERSAW THE INTERNMENT OF UP TO
2 MILLION UYGHURS AND OTHER
MINORITIES AND XINJIANG IN WHAT
TRYING TO CONSERVE OCCASIONAL
TRAINING CENTERS.
HE'S --
VOWING TO REUNITE THE
DEMOCRATIC ISLAND WITH THE
MAINLAND.
CHINA TELLS ITS PEOPLE THAT
ACTIONS ARE NO LONGER OVERDUE.
BUILDING THE NARRATIVE THAT
OVER 100 YEARS OF SUBJUGATION
BY FOREIGN POWERS IN THE 19TH
AND 20TH CENTURIES, CHINA IS
FINALLY ASSUMING ITS RIGHTFUL
PLACE IN THE WORLD.
ANYONE THAT DISAGREES THIS
BLAME FOR TRYING TO UNDERMINE
CHINA'S RISE AND QUICKLY
CENSORED OR EVEN JAILED.
>> IT'S GOING BACK TO HIS
MYTHICAL VISION FOR CHINESE
HISTORY.
WHEN CHINA WAS THE GREATEST
CIVILIZATION AND THE REST OF
THE WORLD WANT TO CHINA.
>> THAT BREMEN HAS RIPPLE
EFFECTS AROUND THE WORLD.
CHINA NO LONGER BELIEVES IT
NEEDS TO PLAY BY AMERICAN-LED
INTERNATIONAL RULES.
WHEN THE U.S. TRIES TO TAKE
CHINA ON TRADE, TECHNOLOGY, OR
HUMAN RIGHTS --
>> THAT REINFORCES THE SENSE
THAT CHINA IS UNDER SIEGE FROM
WESTERN POWERS.
I THINK IT HAS A VISCERAL,
EMOTIONAL, APPEAL IN CHINA.
>> THE COUNTRY IS BUILDING ITS
OWN MULTILATERAL INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE FRIENDLIER TO
AUTOCRATS.
CHINA GIRLS EVER CLOSER TO
RUSSIA, UNIFIED BY COMMON OH.
SHE JINPING'S CHINA DREAM?
THE CHINA'S GLORIOUS AND STRONG,
WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY WITH
1.4 BILLION PEOPLE IN SHAPING A
NEW WORLD ORDER.
SELINA WEIGHING, CNN, HONG KONG.
>> I HAVE JOINED NOW BY STEVEN
JIANG, THEY ARE CHEAP AND
SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT WILL RIPLEY.
THEY'RE STANDING BY IN TAIPEI.
FIRST, YOU DAVID.
24 HOURS LATER, HOW IS MR. XI'S
SPEECH BEING RECEIVED?
>> MICHAEL, IN THIS COUNTRY, TO
SPEECH CAN ONLY BE RECEIVED IN
ONE WAY, WITH RESOUNDING
SUPPORT AND ENTHUSIASM, AS
WE'VE SEEN.
STATE MEDIA AND SOCIAL MEDIA BY
EVERYONE.
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL, CREASE,
POTUS MOMS.
EVEN BRIDES THAT WEDDINGS.
AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY, IT'S OPAQUE SYSTEM
MEANS READING THE SPEECHES LIKE
READING TEA LEAVES.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM PAUSING
SEVERAL TIMES DURING THIS
SPEECH TO CLEAR HIS THROAT AND
ZIP WATER, DRYING ISSUE ON THE
ATTENTION OF HIS STAMINA.
THAT IS IMPORTANT IN THE SYSTEM
OF ONE MAN RULE.
REQUIRING HIM TO MAKE A GROWING
NUMBER OF DECISIONS, MAKE A
SMALL ON INTERNATIONAL FRONTS.
PEOPLE UP AND DIVING DEEP INTO
THAT TWO HOUR SPEECH.
NOTICING ONE OF THE WORDS HAS
USED MOST.
OFTEN IT IS STRUGGLE OR FIGHT.
HE TALKED ABOUT FIGHTING COVID,
FIGHTING CORRUPTION, FIGHTING
SEPARATISTS WITHOUT NAMING THE
U.S., FIGHTING UNILATERALISM.
THIS IS AN INDICATION THAT HE'S
UNLIKELY TO BACK DOWN FROM ANY
OF THE POSITIONS, INCLUDING
ZERO COVID.
ANOTHER PHRASE HE USED GOT
PEOPLES ATTENTION.
HOW HE SAID CHINA IS NOW
ENTERING A PHASE OF STRATEGIC
RISKS AND GROWING UNCERTAINTY.
IN THE PAST, BOTH HE AND HIS
PREDECESSORS HAVE ALWAYS SAID
THAT CHINA IS ENTERING A PHASE
OF STRATEGIC OPPORTUNITIES.
THE NEW PHRASING WOULD ALLOW
DISCUSSIONS AND DEBATE, AS HE
SAYS IN TERMS OF ACCESSING THE
INTERNAL THREAT ENVIRONMENT,
ENVIRONMENT CHINA IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO MOVE RESOURCES,
ALLOCATE RESOURCES MORE TOWARDS
LONG TERM WAR FOOTING AS CHINA
ANTICIPATES THE RISK OR GROWING
RISK OF CONFLICT IN THE WAR.
MICHAEL?
>> YEAH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOUR ANALYSIS,
STEPHEN.
THEY THAT.
WILL RIPLEY, HAS WE DISCUSSED,
MR. XI MADE CLEAR IN HIS SPEECH
'S VIEW OF TAIWAN'S FUTURE AND
INDEPENDENTS.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE RECEPTION TO
THE SPEECH THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, CHINA KEEPS SAYING,
MICHAEL, AS SHE JINPING SAID IT
YESTERDAY, THE PEACEFUL
REUNIFICATION WITH THE ISLAND
THAT THEY'VE NEVER CONTROLLED
SINCE THE END OF CHINA'S CIVIL
WAR, THE SELF GOVERNING
DEMOCRACY HAS BEEN RUNNING ITS
OWN SHOW FOR MORE THAN 70
YEARS.
EVOLVED INTO THIS DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM.
THE PEOPLE, 23 MILLION OF THEM,
ELECTED LEADERS THAT BEIJING
CALLS A LEGITIMATE.
BEIJING'S COMMUNIST RULERS WILL
LAY CLAIM TO THIS ISLAND, YOU
WOULD BE HARD-PRESSED TO FIND
ANYBODY HERE WHO BELIEVES THAT
THE RULERS AND BEIJING HAVE
ROLLOVER THEIR LIVES.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT PEOPLE WANT A
WAR WITH CHINA?
NOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, THE MAJORITY
PEOPLE HERE, CONTINUE TO WANT
TO MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO
WHERE TAIWAN BASICALLY LOOKS
AND ACTS LIKE A COUNTRY,
WITHOUT CALLING ITSELF THAT, OR
AT LEAST WITHOUT MOST OF THE
WORLD CALLING THEM THAT.
BEIJING MAKING SURE THAT THEY
ONLY OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZE CHINA
AS BEIJING.
CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR MILITARY,
THEIR OWN DEMOCRACY.
THEY CONTINUE WITH LIVE AS.
IS IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE MICHAEL,
PEOPLE JUST REOPEN THE BORDERS,
THEY HAVE A MAJOR LGBTQ PRIDE
COMING UP, SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE UNTHINKABLE AND CHINA, OPEN
BORDERS AND THE PRIDE THING.
AS WE'VE SEEN, WHAT HAPPENS TO
--
THEY ARE BASICALLY IN SILENCE.
THE DIFFERENCES ARE CELEBRATED.
THERE'S MORE COLOR IN THE
STREETS HERE.
THERE IS ALSO LESS ORDER.
XI JINPING HAS MADE ORDER HIS
PRIORITY.
YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS, MICHAEL.
NOT TOO MANY PEOPLE HERE WOULD
WILLINGLY REABSORBED WITH THE
CHINA THAT THEY'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW, CERTAINLY WITH THE BOWLING
LOCKDOWNS.
AND MILITARY INTIMIDATION
DOESN'T REALLY PAYS PEOPLE
HERE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH IT
THEIR WHOLE LIVES.
EVEN AS CHINA HAS STEPPED UP,
INTIMIDATION, PEOPLE ARE AWARE
THAT THERE MAY BE A CONFLICT.
THEY SAY THEY'LL BE READY TO
DEFEND THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
>> YEAH.
DE